hey it's Martin garrix and I'm going
undercover on the Internet this actually
me did the NIC Martha Harrison Twitter
Martin garrix I know you won't answer
you're wrong but I tried how would you
describe yourself in three words crazy
happy happy I'm just always happy doing
I would like to know what is your dream
now because you're the number one again
you have your own book and your music is
amazing I've so many dreams I built a
studio complex in the Netherlands with
my team and I want to use it to to build
new talent to showcase them to the world
and my main focus now is just guiding
and giving new talent cool tellin a
platform how would Martin garrix chase
muggers collapse sound like I have no
idea
I think the Garrick chainsmokers song
would be really aggressive just we both
started in like the club festival scene
so we can either do it right your
friendly song getcha melody so would you
like a very aggressive festival club
song I don't know we have to find out
Cora I don't know what Korres but Cora
we show for this morning Garrick use I
use a file studio and to record vocals
we use vocals
FL Studio is just an extension of my
brain if I think of something it takes
me 30 seconds before us in there might
not sound good but the idea is there and
then afterwards I polish it posted more
Twitter do you have any tips to make
your drops harder bigger I just layer a
lot my mix down is the most important I
want the mixer sound perfect without
anything on the moss and when it sounds
fat when it sounds harder when it sounds
big then I start compressing it on the
master so they will give like the extra
punch next one what char are those
Martin garrix produce I have no clue I
just make whatever music I want to make
I even know what I'm making I just make
Gary music on the next one what's a
memory that makes me smell the most I
like this question Nick it's all the
small little things with my family my
friends for me seeing someone's smile as
a moment that makes me smile so if I do
a show and I see thousands of people
smile
I get super happy and makes me smile
from ear to ear so family friendship and
shows Wikipedia in 2004 he expressed
interest in becoming a DJ after seeing
chess to perform at that year's Summer
Olympic ceremony in Athens that is
correct
I'm a useless event he inspired me since
day one and the last couple of years he
took me under his wing and we became
friends which is crazy because I start
making music and fell in love with the
genre because of him says crazy next he
also said his dream mentor was Calvin
Harris that's correct - he's just genius
everything he touches turns into gold
and I love the fact that he just does
whatever he wants to do doesn't think
too much about about genres and
everything it just combines everything
and for me that's very very special back
to Twitter Wireless morning Garrick used
Windows Vista I work with FL Studio and
it just runs on Windows I like free some
more and they just released the version
for Apple but I wasn't better tested for
that one and it just wasn't my vibe
I love Windows next random Friday night
late-night question what's the best
techno song of all time was diggin
animals by martin garrix at the game
last night I'm stoked he loves the song
but it's not techno if you want to call
it techno I love it you have to like my
check yourself so much Twitter question
from at am DJ sk x k sk f k sk c who do
you most want to work with I love
Pharrell such a sick voice such a sick
producer too but also him as a human
being the energy he transmits to the
people around them it's inspiring and
I'm just curious and excited for the
result that will come out of a studio
session will be crazy
next yahoo ends
how that morning Gary's get famous I
just make music and I started in my
bedroom I made my first big song animals
also in my bedroom in my parents house
and I was 1516 when I did it and this
song just exploded but a surprise I have
no idea how I get things people like the
song says great wouldn't Martin garrix
come to be okay for 40 year old and his
friend if supervised sure two weeks ago
an m7 at 118 Plus show and they have to
really the all-ages show so I'm not
doing everywhere around the world but
wherever we can wherever we do the full
Garrick show we try to do two dates so
one is all ages in the other ones 80
plus then Instagram as a number one DJ
how does it feel like you are the only
one in the world no I get to share it
with millions and millions of people and
that makes me makes me really happy I
get to travel the world doing what I
love to do I get to see people smile and
just crazy I'm definitely not feel like
the only one in the world I feel like
everyone is together and that's what I
celebrate reddit morning Eric's voice in
high on life so is it just me or is
there a weird little hiccup around 242
right after bone finishes saying it
almost even sounds like Martin's own
voice
[Applause]
I can't figure out what it's supposed to
be and I don't hear anywhere else in the
song I've literally been wondering about
this since the day this song came out
yet I can't seem to find anything about
it from the internet we'd love to know
what you think I actually know what you
mean it's not my voice if you listen
very carefully can someone say my voice
saying something crazy in a song but
actually not in hire life it's just a
random mistake I made and I bounced out
all the separate stems when I start
mixing a song and then I heard it and it
was something so small I I was hoping no
one who knows it but you did drop state
last question what's the most important
thing that keeps me so happy and
energetic
all the time the shows are super crazy
but afterwards it's like you're mostly
the time by yourself so tell me what I
do right now is I travel with my family
with my friends not all the time but
doesn't make me miss home because they
join me so that that keeps me happy and
energetic that's it Martin garrix
signing out of here thanks for tuning in
and see you soon